THE MOST POWERFUL WOMAN IN
POLITICS
RETURNED TO THE SCENE IN A BIG
WAY.
WE HAVE BEEN EXPECTING TO HEAR
FROM HER, AND, WOW, SHE REALLY
CAME OUT STRONG.
>> I'M NOT A POLITICIAN.
I'M A QUEEN.
>> Larry: OK, THAT'S KHALEESI,
FROM "GAME OF THRONES," BUT
HILLARY CLINTON ALSO ANNOUNCED
SHE'S SEEKING THE CROWN
YESTERDAY.
>> I'M RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: LOOK, HILLARY'S NOT
THAT FAR OFF FROM KHALEESI.
I'M SURE SHE WOULD ALSO SAY
SOMETHING LIKE THIS --
>> AND I WILL TAKE WHAT IS MINE.
WITH FIRE AND BLOOD I WILL TAKE
IT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: I SMELL A CAMPAIGN
SLOGAN!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> THAT'S RIGHT, I WILL TAKE IT
THIS DOES MAKE SENSE.
BOTH HILLARY AND KHALEESI FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE A BIRTHRIGHT TO
THE THRONE AND FEEL LIKE THEIR
KINGDOM WAS STOLEN FROM THEM A
FEW YEARS AGO.
THEY'VE BOTH BEEN THROUGH A LOT,
STARTING WITH THEIR STRATEGIC
MARRIAGES TO HORNY WARLORDS.
THEY BOTH SPENT YEARS STRUGGLING
IN A LAND OF SPITEFUL, BARBARIC
HORSEPEOPLE.
BUT THE REASON THEY HAVEN'T
ASCENDED YET IS BECAUSE THEIR
RIGHTFUL BLOODLINE WAS DEPOSED
BY THE NATION'S MOST POWERFUL
GOLD-HOARDING DYNASTY.
YOU KNOW THEM, THE COLD,
CALCULATING PATRIARCH WHO, FROM
THE SIDELINES, HAS BEEN
MANIPULATING HIS FAMILY INTO
POSITIONS OF POWER...
THE INEPT TORTURE-LOVING BULLY
WHO FAMOUSLY CHOKED AT A
BANQUET...
AND THE HEIR-APPARENT SON WHO
PEOPLE LIKE IN SPITE OF ALL THE
RED FLAGS AND WHO TRAGICALLY
JUST LOST HIS RIGHT HAND.
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
SO SAD.
I KNOW.
SAD.
THE BIGGEST COMPETITION RIGHT
NOW, OF COURSE, IS THE DARK
HORSE FROM THE FRINGES, WHO HAS
THE COURAGE OF HIS CONVICTIONS
BUT HAS BEEN TURNED CRAZY BY
RELIGION.
(LAUGHTER)
ALSO HODOR.